[Applaudissements]
franck dubosc ados cloud merci d'être là
franck des vases à comment il va j'ai
posé j'ai posé mauvais tout sur deux
femmes non c'est vrai ah bah jean michel
maire était sur les dossiers sachez
comment ça va donc généralement franck
wiimote vous voir franck on vous
retrouve au casino de paris du 27
novembre au 5 janvier on a hâte de vous
revoir sur scène les téléspectateurs or
at on a tous acquis si on va en parler
dans un instant en fait là on va partir
ont pu mais on vient juste après avec
vous est-ce que vous avez quelque chose
à dire aux français jusqu'avant des
années 10 secondes
si vous restez avec nous sur cette
antenne
on peut dire antenne encore un oui on
peut le dire oui peut-être que je me
mettrais comme ça tu me comprends pas si
vous reprenez l'antenne jeu sur cognac g
je serai là et peut-être même nu voilà
et pour les amis de gérard louvin
brancher votre magnétoscope
ça va être on aura une surprise pour
franck dubosc dans un instant